nachbessern fürs klima bund und länder
machen öl und sprit teurer
entlastung gibt es für pendler und beim
strom gipfel gegen fachkräftemangel
deutschland will die zuwanderung gut
ausgebildete ausländer erleichtern die
achtelfinals in der champions league
dortmund trifft auf paris mit ex coach
tuchel münchen und leipzig müssen in
london an
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster und abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am 16 dezember
und auch christian otto ist hier für den
sport in wenigen minuten auch sehr gerne
einen schönen guten abend während der
klimagipfel in madrid engagierte die
klimaschützer enttäuscht hat wurde das
klimapaket in deutschland auf drängen
der grünen deutlich nachgebessert damit
demnächst auch der bundesrat zustimmen
kann
so hat die koalition zum beispiel den
einstiegspreis für co2 nun doch erhöht
ab 2021 kostet die tonne statt der
bisher geplanten zehn jetzt 25 euro bis
2025 steigt der preis schrittweise auf
55 euro an
die mehreinnahmen will der staat an die
stromkunden zurückgeben das bedeutet für
einen zwei-personen-haushalt zunächst
eine entlastung von rund 60 euro
auch wer länger zur arbeit fährt soll
entlastet werden die pendlerpauschale
wird jetzt zweimal erhöht 2021 wie
vorgesehen um 5 und 2024 um weitere 3
cent vertritt sabine meyer
es war vor allem der im klimapaket der
regierung enthaltene co2 preis von zehn
euro die tonne der in der kritik stand
so niedrig ohne lenkungswirkung so die
argumente
jetzt also soll er deutlich höher
ausfallen das ist ein kompromiss aber
ich glaube es ein guter kompromiss würde
auf der einen seite die co2 preise
maßvolle heute noch auf der anderen
seite aber auch den ausgleich vergibt
ein höherer co2 preis bedeutet dass
benzin schon im ersten jahr etwa sieben
bis acht cent pro liter mehr kosten
könnte auch heizöl und gas würden teurer
im gegenzug sollen die bürger entlastet
werden ebenfalls deutlicher als geplant
durch eine höhere pendlerpauschale
billigeren strom und günstigeres bahn
fahren sind meine augen gute vorschläge
die dafür sorgen dass das klimapaket
besser werden kann dass wir mehr
klimaschutz betreiben
aber auch einen höheren sozialen
ausgleich zufrieden sind auch die grünen
die über ihre landesminister druck
gemacht und einen höheren co2 preis
durchgesetzt haben dass ein schritt in
die richtige richtung mehr nicht aber so
kann der preis endlich auch eine wirkung
entfalten und dafür sorgen dass wir
nicht ein anreiz allein für mehr
autofahren haben
deutlichere kritik dagegen kommt von
klimaforschern und der linkspartei
das was jetzt nachgebessert wird durch
den bundesrat und was jetzt als
kompromiss erzielt wird bleibt weit
hinter dem zurück was wir eigentlich
dringend brauchen würden wir bräuchten
eigentlich einen höheren preis 50 euro
einstiegspreis der dann über die zeit
auf 130 euro ansteigt bis 2030 das wären
signal was dann konsistent wäre so dass
wir unsere klimaschutzziele für 2030
einheiten können weitere schritte
müssten jetzt folgen beim kohleausstieg
beim ökostrom und der verkehrswende
darin sind sich umweltverbände grüne und
linke einig ja und auch die
wissenschaftlich sich längst einig dass
die zeit in sachen klimaschutz drängt
im internet haben wir fakten und zahlen
zur erderwärmung zusammengestellt auf
heute.de der sprit wird also auch
schrittweise teurer dafür soll das
bahnfahren attraktiver werden
die tickets werden billiger weil für sie
die mehrwertsteuer gesenkt wird und
damit schon bald immer mehr menschen von
der straße auf die schiene wechseln
können baut die bahn ihren fuhrpark
massiv aus sogar ic verbindungen in 30
minuten takt sind geplant hans jürgen
pohl berichtet er soll das rückgrat der
verkehrswende werden vor allem mit
solchen ic 4 will die bahn 20 prozent
mehr sitzplatzkapazität schaffen
in den nächsten sechs jahren investiert
der staatskonzern dafür insgesamt zwölf
milliarden euro in neue längere züge wie
der vorstand jetzt vorrechnete
fahrzeugflotte ist heute 22 jahre alt im
deutschen wir wollen sie vor genau 15
jahre im durchschnitt
wir werden zusätzliche werke in betrieb
nehmen und wir werden und haben schon
zusätzliche mitarbeiter eingestellt
so sollen bis 2026 137 ec vier ältere
zug modelle ersetzen
dazu kommen 86 zusätzliche doppelstock
intercity 23 euro city des spanischen
herstellers tango und 30 schnellzüge für
die eine ausschreibung noch aussteht
gleichzeitig denkt die bahn bereits über
eine erneuerung des flotten flaggschiffs
ic3 nach so könnte danach folge zug
durchaus auch ein doppelstock modell
sein wie sie bereits in frankreich oder
japan unterwegs sind fernziel aber ist
ein halbstundentakt zwischen den
großstädten schon im übernächsten jahr
sollen ece zwischen berlin und hamburg
alle 30 minuten fahren
deutschlandweit ist das aber noch
zukunftsmusik das ziel ist toll
es wird nur dauer dieses realisiert wird
und keiner soll glauben dass es morgen
oder 2025 schon realisiert ist der reden
da über 20 30 bis 20 40 und manche die
es heute versprechen werde es nicht mehr
erleben
hauptgrund das schienennetz muss für die
häufigen fahrten erst noch ausgebaut
werden denn schon heute fast an
knotenpunkten kein zusätzlicher zug mehr
ausgleich dann heute noch zahlen die den
bemühungen um weniger emissionen zuwider
laufen
sie kommen vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt
demnach wird der luftverkehr in den
nächsten jahrzehnten dramatisch zunehmen
vor allem in asien von derzeit jährlich
weltweit 4 milliarden wird sich die zahl
der flugpassagiere in 20 jahren auf 9,6
milliarden mehr als verdoppelt haben
ohne fachkräfte aus dem ausland das
zeigen alle studien wird deutschland
seinen wohlstand nicht halten können so
lautet die frage auch nicht mehr ob
sondern wie man die zuwanderung
organisieren soll
die konkurrenz in aller welt ist groß
deutschland aber tut sich schwer woran
das liegt sagt uns damit sauer als
größtes geschäftsrisiko bezeichnen 56
prozent der firmen in deutschland den
fachkräftemangel vor allem für
akademiker sind andere länder deutlich
attraktiver in einer aktuellen oecd
studie die die attraktivität von ländern
vergleicht landet die bundesrepublik auf
rang 12 hinter ländern wie slowenien
irland deutschland macht es
ausländischen fachkräften relativ schwer
die vergabe von visa ist kompliziert und
oft langwierig berufs und
studienabschlüsse werden oft nicht
anerkannt
bei den nettolöhnen landet deutschland
auf den hinteren plätzen steuern und
sozialabgaben sind im vergleich sehr
hoch wichtig auch die rahmenbedingungen
für die familie etwa die kinderbetreuung
oder die jobaussichten für lebenspartner
versuch deutschland für ausländische
fachkräfte attraktiver zu machen wenn
nun die bundesregierung starten mit
einem ersten einwanderungsgesetz doch
wie soll es ausgestaltet werden
vom gipfel mit wirtschaftsvertretern im
kanzleramt berichtet frank buchwald
kilimanjaro hat es geschafft bei einer
firma am flughafen frankfurt hahn hat
der mann aus der türkei seinen traumjob
gefunden
er arbeitet als aircraft engineering nie
leicht aber war der weg nach deutschland
für ihn nicht wir haben vier oder
fünfmal versucht eine arbeitserlaubnis
für mich zu bekommen aber die anträge
wurden immer wieder abgelehnt erst beim
sechsten oder siebten versuch aber erst
angeschafft
es ist für ausländer extrem schwierig
hier zu arbeiten wenn sie nicht aus der
eu kommen
deutschland will attraktiver werden für
fachkräfte aus dem ausland
spitzentreffen deshalb heute bei der
kanzlerin
im märz tritt das fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz in kraft viele
details aber sind noch offen
es geht jetzt darum das gemeinsam mit
der wirtschaft mit leben zu erfüllen die
wirtschaft muss selbst an
werbestrategien entwickeln
wir müssen als staat dafür sorgen dass
in der praxis bürokratische hürden
bekommen geht es um die anerkennung von
beruflichen qualifikationen da geht es
um sprache und nicht zuletzt auch um die
frage wie das mit visums verteilung ist
für die opposition aber ist die neue
regelung selbst immer noch viel zu
bürokratisch
wir brauchen ein klares punktesystem wo
sowohl akademischer als auch berufliche
ausbildungen und erfahrungen bewertet
werden zusätzlich die sprachkenntnisse
merkmale die integrations förderlich
sind müssen klar bewertet werden wir
brauchen ein klares signal denn wir sind
bisher nicht attraktiv genug
das gilt übrigens nicht nur für hightech
berufe auch handwerker suchen dringend
leute schon damit ihre kunden nicht ewig
warten müssen ein besonderes weltkriegs
gedenken heute in belgien denn vor genau
75 jahren unternimmt das naziregime
einen letzten gruß angriff um die
alliierten doch noch zurück zu drängen
mit verheerenden folgen
im dezember 1944 startet die wehrmacht
die sogenannte ardennenoffensive in
belgien und teilen luxemburgs das ziel
die hafenstadt antwerpen um die
versorgung der alliierten abzuschneiden
doch das gelingt nicht in der kleinstadt
bastogne kommt es zu einer blutigen
belagerung zehntausende sterben darunter
viele us soldaten über den gedenktag
wunder krüger gedenken mit fanfaren und
staatschefs doch für gefühle sorgt eine
kleine anekdote malcolm marsch aus
alabama steht weihnachten 1944 auf
posten im schneesturm der ardennen
plötzlich kommt eine bergische frau aus
dem haus sie reicht mir und meinem
kameraden zwei heiße tassen hühnerbrühe
es war wohl die beste die ich je
getrunken habe 75 jahre danach spricht
hier zum ersten mal ein deutscher
bundespräsident
wir stehen tief in der schuld dieses
amerikas das unseren demokratischen
neubeginn begleitete trotz des krieges
und trotz der show am morgen des 16
dezember war die wehrmacht erneut nach
belgien vorgestoßen überraschend und
brutal auch gegen gefangene und
zivilisten
wir saßen dort im keller oben die
amerikaner und da drüben die deutschen
magie marin zeigt uns wo ein geschoss
einschlug es explodierte nicht sie
überlebte nach der befreiung ist
bastogne ein trümmerfeld aber in den usa
vorteil das symbol für den chor den
guten krieg den sie gekämpft haben
im zweiten weltkrieg war amerika bereit
alles zu geben um die freiheit zu retten
und unsere lebensart zu schützen
doch würden die usa heute dasselbe tun
heute nicht mehr glaubt magie mehr in
unsere sicht auf die amerikaner hat sich
in den letzten jahren ja leider auch
geändert den ordner mit ihren
erinnerungen bekommen ihre enkel damit
sie den krieg nie vergessen
der britische premierminister johnson
will seinen braig citydeal jetzt rasch
umsetzen
bereits an diesem freitag soll das
unterhaus darüber abstimmen
johnsons konservative verfügen nach dem
überwältigenden wahlsieg vergangene
woche über eine absolute mehrheit die
zustimmung zum rexit abkommen gilt daher
als sicher
seit monaten sind die beziehungen
zwischen den usa und der türkei
angespannt nun droht der türkische
präsident erdogan damit zwei wichtige
stützpunkte für das us militär zu
schließen
die luftwaffenbasis incirlik und die
radarstation krejcik das deutete erdogan
in einem fernsehinterview
hintergrund des streits weil ankara im
sommer ein russisches
raketenabwehrsystem gekauft hat fordern
us-senatoren sanktionen gegen die türkei
der fisch in nordsee und atlantik ist
heute und morgen thema der
eu-fischereiminister es geht um die
fangquoten für das kommende jahr
lange zeit waren die meisten fischarten
in der nordsee überfischt
doch die situation hat sich teilweise
verbessert dank strengerer fangquoten
konnte sich zum beispiel die schule in
den vergangenen jahren deutlich erholen
anders geht es dem kabeljau sein bestand
ist seit den 80er jahren unter der
nachhaltigkeits grenze heißt er ist akut
bedroht
dabei spielt auch das klima eine rolle
die nordsee hat sich seit den 60er
jahren um 1,7 grad erwärmt der kabeljau
und auch andere fischarten wandern daher
in kühle gebiete abwählen tacke
berichtet die fangsaison von dieter
uhlmann ist für dieses jahr vorbei sein
kutter geht sonst auf der nordsee auf
fischfang der kapitän aus dem
niedersächsischen brake ist vorsitzender
einer fischereigenossenschaft mit
insgesamt 32 kuttern
wie in jedem jahr erwartet er die
festlegung der fangquoten mit spannung
ich erwarte gemäßigte reduzierung und
auch erhöhung also das was geplant ist
70 prozent minderung des kabeljaus geht
gar nicht es ist ein unding für die
fischerei überfischung aber auch die
erwärmung des wassers durch den
klimawandel haben zu einer gefährdung
der kabeljau bestände in der nordsee
geführt so das ergebnis
wissenschaftlicher untersuchungen für
diese bestandserhebung ist in
deutschland das thünen institut für
seefischerei in bremerhaven zuständig
also wie es die struktur
mir ist der altersaufbau wie sind die
sterblichkeitsraten und aus diesen
informationen die wir mit eigenen
forschungsschiffen erheben und zum teil
auch aus der kommerziellen fischerei aus
den logbüchern der fischer bekommen
rechnen wir im großen demographischen
modellen hoch wie für fische gibt es
überhaupt wie viel scholle hering
rotbarsch oder kabeljau dürfen im
atlantik und in der nordsee gefangen
werden in der regel folgt die kommission
den empfehlungen der wissenschaftler
die fangquoten haben in den letzten
fünfzehn zwanzig jahren dazu geführt
dass wir von 90 prozent überfischt der
fischbestände auf 30 prozent runter
gekommen sind
somit hat sich die fangquoten regelung
nachhaltig ausgewirkt die gute nachricht
für die fischer für den heringsfang wird
eine zunahme der quote um rund 40
prozent empfohlen weil sich die bestände
in den vergangenen jahren erholt haben
wegen der buschbrände in australien
waren die ärzte vor einem
gesundheitsnotstand in sydney
der rauch enthalte eine große menge
winziger partikel und sei für menschen
besonders gefährlich in der region um
sydney wüten seit wochen mehr als 100
brände
trotz aller bemühungen bekommt die
feuerwehr die flammen nicht unter
kontrolle
insgesamt brennen fast 400.000 hektar
land eine fläche etwas größer als
mallorca harter schnitt zum sport
spannende auslosung in der
fußball-champions-league und da werden
ja sehr interessante gegner auf die
deutschen kann wirklich sagen äußerst
reizvoll klar ist im achtelfinale gibt
es keine leichten gegner von harmlosen
ist die rede
der bvb muss gegen seinen früheren
trainer ran und der rekordmeister sowie
der aktuelle bundesliga tabellenführer
bekommen es mit englischen verein zu tun
die bayern treffen auf chelsea leipzig
auf tottenham und dortmund auf paris mit
ex trainer thomas tuchel große
wiedersehensfreude kommt da nicht auf
der sitzt trainer bei pc und macht er
seinen job und behörden ihn natürlich
einer dann je nach dortmund zurück
kommen freundlich begrüßen
böse erinnerungen an 2012 werden bei den
bayern war final niederlage gegen
chelsea das viertelfinale trotzdem fest
eingeplant genau so wollen wir auch in
diese spiele gehen
ja wir wollen auch der favorit und dem
müssen wir gerecht werden
julia nagelsmann und leipzig treffen bei
ihrer achtelfinal premiere auf
vorjahresfinalist todtmoos am 18 februar
geht es los mit der ersten ko runde
ja und zwei tage danach mit der
zwischenrunde in der europa league auch
mit attraktiven gegnern für die drei
deutschen vereine alle zunächst mit
heimvorteil eintracht frankfurt trifft
auf den österreichischen meister rb
salzburg bei leverkusen auf portugals
topklub fc porto und wolfsburg auf die
schweden von malmö ff eine
stimmungsvolle gala voller hochkarätiger
sportlerinnen und sportler gestern abend
in baden-baden zum abschluss des
vorolympischen jahres bei der wahl
sportler des jahres ein triumph für zwei
leichtathleten und ein trainer mit einem
weltmeisterlichen skisprung-team die
sportler des jahres das ist natürlich
die krönung was ich glaube dass es die
die höchste auszeichnung die ein
sportler in deutschland gewinnen kann
wenn eine weitsprung weltmeisterin
barfuß klavier spielt und laudator frank
busemann seine fliege von 1996 hat zeigt
dann haben sportjournalisten die
richtigen gewählt
das bestimmt warum ich diese hässliche
fliege er trage aber die von vor 23
jahren als ich hier stehen durfte und
gar nicht begriffen habe was diese
ehrung wert war
eine ehrung als oscar des sports auch
für eine überfliegerin dieses diese
tolle saison jetzt auch noch mit der
auszeichnung hier geehrt und eine wahl
mit potenzial ob das was dann noch kommt
olympia 2020
absolut das wird ein mega sport ja schön
und wir haben das wetter noch eine woche
vor weihnachten stehen die zeichen
allerdings eher auf frühling als auf
winter ob und wann es endlich wieder
kälter wird oder ob es kälter wird
erklärt gleich katja honnefer das war es
von uns schön dass er doch dass sie
dabei waren das heute journal mit claus
kleber um 21 uhr 45 und wir sind dann
morgen abend wieder zur stelle punkt 7
[Musik]
meine damen und herren haben sie lust
nach sternschnuppen ausschau zu halten
heute abend hätten sie gelegenheit und
zwar in einem breiten streifen hier von
brandenburg bis nach baden württemberg
das sind die geminiden und wenn sie
richtung osten richtung mond schauen
dann können sie vielleicht die eine oder
andere sternschnuppe entdecken
vielleicht im laufe der nacht selbst in
niedersachsen oder bremen regen brauchen
sie dabei kaum zu befürchten den gibt's
allenfalls mann in der mitte oder auch
im nordwesten und an der unteren donau
bildet sich zum teil dichter nebel da
kann es also platz seien auf den straßen
denn dort sinken die temperaturen in den
frost nämlich bis minus 3 grad sonst
bleibt die nacht deutlich milder bei 9
bis 4 grad und morgen wird es
frühlingshaft mild mit
höchsttemperaturen zwischen 10 grad in
flensburg und 17 grad mit föhn
unterstützung in oberstdorf oder auch in
garmisch das sollte für die meisten ein
sehr freundlicher dienstag und erst zum
abend kommen dann von westen neuer regen
wolken heran und dazu greift dieser
böige wind aus südlichen richtungen
in der nacht auf mittwoch überquert uns
das regenband von west nach ost am
mittwoch ist der regen schon fast
abgezogen danach geht es ruhig weiter
den nächsten regen gibt es erst am
freitag es bleibt mild schön ab noch